賞物大了幾看多
接近一半的人
要解定存買股票
很多老手一看都是新聞
第一反應是貌人害
想說慘了
差鞋從來了
愛顧可能要崩盤了
但是賞物一天看好
真的就等於大崩盤的前兆嗎
最近台股非常火热
几乎人人都在聊股票
看了台股指数一路旷飙
从去年年底26000到现在冲破48000点
你是不是也开始觉得再不买
就真的来不及了
如果你有这种formal的感觉
很怕错过是擅长的感觉
也就是所谓的错失恐惧症
别担心你不孤单
你不是唯一一个
根据国贷金贡网
在2026年6月最新公布的调查报告
台股迎来了史上最强的信心
我们来看看两组数据资料
第一 民众对台股的乐观指数
从5月的45.5
一口气喷发到6月的54.5
风险偏向指数更是冲上40.6
算算下历史新高
另外一点更夸张
高达49.6%
就将近一半的民众表示
他们想把手上的现金
甚至想要减约定存
拿来投资股市
这个比例是史上第一次超越了
选择暗兵不动的人的
连最保守的定存族都想要解约买股票
很多老手一看到这新闻
第一反应是冒冷汗
想说惨了
擦鞋头来了
台股可能要崩盘了
但是赏户一片看好
真的就等于大崩盘的见证吗
我们先来科普一下
为什么大家这么怕赏户解定存
在华尔街有一个非常著名的
擦鞋头理论
1929年美股大崩盘之前
老甘乃迪
甘乃迪总统的爸爸
在街边给擦鞋头擦皮鞋
没想到
那一位连饭都快吃不饱的插钱头
竟然兴致勃勃的跟他报名牌
告诉他买哪支股票会赚钱
老干的一听啊
心想连自然上最底层最没有闲钱的人都在炒股哦那还有谁能拿出钱来继续买股票呢所以他回去后立刻出清所有股票不久后美股果然崩盘迎来了历史上最惨烈的经济大萧条
我们把镜头拉回到亚洲
这种散户极度疯狂
导致股市见顶的案例
历史上比比皆是
我们就来看1990年代台股
当时有一句话说
台湾钱烟角木
蔡兰族全民大运动
台股本一比炒到100倍
结果台湾股市从12682
一路团泄到2485点
跌幅高达80%
另外1989年的日股
有没有印象
那时候也是日股美好一年
日本企业与赏户
全民都炒房炒股
认为日本No.1
山林地所甚至以2000亿日元的天价
买下纽约的洛克斐勒中心
结果日经指数从38915点开始崩溃
开启了失落的30年
再来看看
2021年的台股航海王热潮
人人都爱单水手
连大学生都拿着几万块学费
进场开杠杆想买货柜寒英股
最终蝉龙从233元一路崩跌到只剩85.5元
跌幅高达63%
无数产户被断头洗出场
这又为什么
当很多人看到国泰经的报告说
接近一半的人想要解定存买股票
老手会感到恐惧
因为这代表筹码很凌乱
只要稍微有一点点风吹草动
就会容易引发口欢性的多沙多
听到这里你觉得应该要出清股票吗?
且慢,如果金融市场这么简单
大家早就发财了
我反而举一些例子说
产物大举看多
而且股市却继续喷发的反例
从1995年到1996年的网路泡沫前期
网路发展初期
产物疯狂涌入网路相关科技股
当时肺的主席葛林斯潘
在1996年年底就公开警告
市场已经出现非理性繁荣
哇,1996年就说了
而且是肺的主席说
他警告那时候
纳斯达克指数三年已经涨了快一倍
来到1300点附近
那是不是你应该要听他的警告就下车了
我告诉你
如果听他的警告下车的话
你会错过后面长达4年
涨幅更惊人的股市啊
因为当他讲了以后
股市来到2000点的时候又大涨将近4倍来到5000点的时候才真正见顶这就是为什么我看好这个行情有小浮泡沫但小浮泡沫不用紧张大浮泡沫的时候在紧张
从以前到现在
抓回档
本来就不是一件很简单的事情
那我们再举另外一个例子
2020年的台股
当台湾股市第一次突破
12682的历史天险的时候
散户零股的交易人数
创下历史新高
全民丰买台积电
但是如果你那时候觉得
散户太多而跑掉
你反而撞不到后来台湾股市
从8523点涨到1 8619点的那一段大行情
那为什么散户进场不会立刻崩?
有三个原因
第一个资金接半
散户解约定存的钱
刚好接手了大部分法人获利了结的筹码
只要基本面够强
记住这句话基本面够强
这股庞大的资金就可能成为
推生大盘的活水
第二嘎空行情
当散户疯狂的时候
很多自重聪明的大户或机构
这年散户都会觉得过热而去放空
结果大盘继续涨
这些空单被迫停损买回
什么叫停存买回?
停存买回就是
上空我现在变做多把它买回来
那这些买回反而变成推升指数的买盘
第三
多头人金晶产特性
华尔街有一句名言说
行情总是在
绝望中诞生
在半信半信中成长
在憧憬中成熟
在希望中回灭
赏户乐观代表市场进入成熟期
而这个成熟期有时候可以维持几个月
甚至好几年
所以重点是不在于赏户到底有多乐观
而这一波上涨有没有真实的获利支撑
今天台湾股市有办法突破48000点的利息新高
我们不能只看情绪
要看基本面
而且目前美伊停站进入谈判了
但油价明显下滑
也会轻轻轰蓬压力
美国FED并没有普尔切升息的必要性
这对股市来说是第一个利多
而更重要的第二项利多
就是AI产业的实质获利正在包充
今天AI
早就不是当初只能聊天人、机器人
甚至AI助理
AI自家车
AI医疗都在快速发展
微软、Google、亚马逊
为了训练更强大的AI模型
疯狂扩建资料中心
再加上全球AI自动驾驶的普及
台湾特斯拉、FSD都快要上了
以及人型机器人的三样化
这些都会带来极度庞大的经济效应和现金流
只要企业有强劲的EPS坐后盾
这跟1990年代那种本益比高达100倍纯粹靠资金堆叠出来的泡沫有这本事上的不同现在赏物虽然疯狂但他们买的是一家家正在赚大钱的世界企业
那时候 网路泡沫的时候
很多公司根本没赚钱
然后就大展特展
但是你现在没有发现到
赏物很理性
历史案例确实告诉我们
赏物太乐观
反而可能会引发崩盘
但同样的历史证明
股市在崩盘之前
可以带这份乐观继续狂飙
而且有时候连绷跑都没有
还是继续狂飙
这就像我们看技术分析里面指标
教科书上面说
KD指标大于80
就超买
就过热了
随时会回答
但有经验人都知道
在强势多头里面
有一种现象叫做高胆盾化
指标一直在80以上
一直过了
一直震荡
一路盾化
背离可以一直背离
一直背离
一直背离下去
骨架是不回头
继续缓散碰
所以面对现在的台股
我建议绝对不要去预设高点
但一定要严格控管风险
如果你想要解定存进场
也不要一次all in
请分批布局
并永远保留二到三成的现金
不论怎么样
你要all in也没关系
但绝对不要去融资
只要你融资
只要你干干
只要你借钱
甚至买两倍的ETF
当你行情看错
你又不停准的时候
不论你有多少钱
都不够赔
在赞争台湾股市到7万点
8万点
来个超级大回档
1万点 2万点回档
可是不好意思
逼是你的股票是4万点去买进
你还是大赚特赚
只要你不用融资的话
我不知道每个人习惯
如果你当然经验老到
你想要适度的用部分融资
或许可以接受
但如果我是一个分析师
我要面对这么多的产物朋友
我跟你最好建议就是说
那你就不要用融资
你也不要去赌
记住这些预告
把它记在脑海里面
对你只有好处
看懂AI的基本面
做好资金的控管
你就能在这场
全民疯狂的AI派对中
成为最清醒
把钱赚走的聪明投资人
我们台股爆爆爆本周就在此结束
如果你觉得不错的话
欢迎订阅我们频道开启小铃铛
约上我们下周六再会
我们100万粉丝订阅我们频道啦
也谢谢大家
没有这么多粉丝支持
我们不可能100万个粉丝愿意订阅我们频道
也是全南方唯一一位分析师
能达到此项历程碑的
欢迎订阅我们频道开启小铃铛